let's go to the phone lines is that who
i think that is there chris brockman yes
line one line one stephen in memphis
tennessee you're here on the rich eisen
show what's up steven
hey rich this is uh stephen bailey's
father
uh from the combine and just wanted to
call and uh
thank you and how grateful we are to
what you do what you do for the children
at st
jude is pretty special man and my
my son on the plane ride all the way
back to memphis um
on monday that's all he has been talking
about and went to school yesterday
and just i mean man i just i just want
to thank you again and
i i you know tell everybody what saint
jude has done for you
and and bailey and your family please i
mean
it was just bailey was a uh we were
fortunate enough to be
here in town um and live in a suburb of
memphis germantown tennessee so have
have saint jude in in our own
backyard and um bailey had been
complaining about
um pain in his leg uh running
cross-country
and he had been complaining about for a
few months well you know typical sports
dad well
hey man suck it up you know you're not
training enough for
or you know you're gonna be all right
well um
his mama is a physical therapist so she
finally
after it never went away discovered
something wasn't right she took him to
the local sports
clinic and they referred us to saint
jude and
bailey over the last cenium leg from
going from about his hip
to about you know um middleweights to
his shin
and then he got an infection that
prosthetics are known for so that was
another battle but
um so everything's good um bailey went
back to school yesterday
um and we just found out today he he was
up at st you today doing this
physical therapy that he's fixing to
start to go back to school full time
so he is the money that rich raises
that's what it goes to the healing kids
they're fixing to build a huge research
center
and the research is going to be so they
can help to figure out
you know why is this happening kids and
possibly prevent it
and and like rich said on the broadcast
i mean we were fortunate to be
in memphis there's a lot of people there
that have the
parents that have to quit their job and
move to memphis
and and saint jude provides them housing
provides them meals
and just just to worry about getting
their children better
and it's a it's a beautiful special
place and
and we're blessed to live here where it
is
and and rich what you like i said what
you've done the money is this
is my family i know was for forever
grateful and when i told you that was
when you saw us throw in the football on
the sideline yeah stadium that was the
first time i'd thrown the football on my
son in over a year
and that was pretty special and there he
is in the dark jersey and dak tweeted at
him too right
what that was we still can't figure out
how that happened but that was pretty
cool
that was pretty cool so um he has been
following back ever since he was
shoot dax freshman year at mississippi
state
so well stephen i appreciate the call
it is the least i can do um and
uh i'm so thrilled to hear that that
bailly is on the mend and hopefully
never having to deal with that ever
again
well that's what we hope and pray man
but buddy you keep doing what you're
doing man you there
there's good people in the world and
you're you're you're one of them
and you tell mike bailey's after him
about being the the uh
the official timer now hey uh he's hired
he is hired bailly is hired stephen okay
if you want to run under six now i think
bailly's got that
thumb right well he he tied me in five
nine eight
and then the the official time at the
combine is starts with a hand
and ends electronically and i was five
nine
six eight according to that and bailey
had me at five nine eight
mike was a lot more way off than that so
bailey is hired
stephen okay well he that's what he's
been talking about
he showed it to his he showed it to his
orthopedic doctor today
you know how a 13 year old is he thinks
he talks to in a high pitch
and you know they're so insecure i was
like buddy you did fine
and um his orthopedic surgeon they had
he had that appointment today and he
just loved it
well uh tell bailey i said hi um
i loved meeting him love meeting you too
um and let's stay in touch okay we'll do
man you guys are awesome thanks for
everything you got it that's uh stephen
in memphis um nfl.com
run richrun we still the donate button
still works people you just heard it
you heard what the money goes to and
there are people who are
uh even less fortunate than stephen who
is local
i mean right there so many people have
to uproot their lives
go to the campus in tennessee and they
don't see a bill
they don't see a bill for groceries they
don't see a bill for health care they
don't see a bill for
housing they don't see a bill because
saint jude wants
the family to focus on the kids and the
kids focusing on getting better end of
story
nfl.com run richrun for more rich eisen
show
tune to audience channel 239 on directv
or download the rich eisenshow app